hi there Steve garpin here and today I
want to talk about something very
important
and that is that language earning is not
that complicated the reason I want to
talk about that is because I was going
through my library here uh in the
section where I have books on language
acquisition language learning many of
which I bought 20 years ago when we were
getting started with link
and I was reading up on the subject on
attending conferences and so forth and I
went back through some of these books
and I realized just how complicated the
sort of
language acquisition academics make the
subject of a language learning it's
really not that complicated and so I
wanted to go through with you some of
the books that I have and some of the
concepts that appear in these books you
know learning book second language
acquisition Rod Alice vocabulary
description acquisition and pedagogy
learning vocabulary in another language
vocabulary in language teaching uh you
know Applied Linguistics
I mean there's lots okay I even have a
Swedish or unless a performance I mean I
used to wherever I was and I would go
into a bookstore and and see what there
was on this subject
and they make it so complex because what
the language acquisition experts with
the exception of saving aggression what
they try to do is describe it's as if
language learning is a motion picture
and they're going to describe it frame
by frame
uh or even not a motion picture but a
animated cartoon where every little step
every little possibility is explained
whereas actually is a very simple
natural phenomenon it's the process of
acquiring new language habits largely
through a lot of listening and reading
and the kind for example uh I don't want
to pick on this one because this Rod
Ellis second language acquisition is in
many ways the best of all these books
because it's short and sweet not as good
as krashen who has a number of very
short books explaining language
acquisition but some of the things he
refers to here and I jotted some of them
down so that I could more easily go
through them so first of all he goes to
Great length to explain that the order
of acquisition depends on the learner's
native language again that's obvious if
you don't have articles in your own
language articles in English or in
languages which have articles are going
to be more difficult to learn
if you don't have plurals in your own
language plurals which would be
absolutely easy for someone who speaks a
language that has plurals is that's
going to be a lot more difficult
to get right each time if you're not
used to the idea that every plural noun
ha you know might have to add an s or do
something that indicates that it's
plural so it's an obvious thing uh again
he goes into all the different kinds of
contexts that influence how a learner
learns the linguistic context the
situational context the psycholinguistic
contest the form function mappings
fossilization all of these things that
affect house in the process whereby a
learner learns but it doesn't influence
how the learner learns the learner still
has to learn the same way through
massive input through massive listing
and reading talks about learner language
and the properties of learner language
and how again you know the forms of the
kinds of Errors a learner makes are
influenced by all of these things
um then he talks about
you know social distance and he gives an
example of of a perhaps I think was a
Japanese person learning English and the
teacher made reference to Bart Simpson
of The Simpsons and she didn't know what
that was and that then created the
social distance for her between the
language she was learning English and
you know not feeling part of that
culture well of course that's always a
part of language acquisition you're
acquiring a language that's initially
quite distant eventually gets closer as
you get closer to the language and as
you engage with content
cultural aspects of that language it
becomes less and less distant but along
the way there are going to be things
that remind you that you're trying to
get into this other culture talks about
different discourse rules that you know
in American society if if someone makes
a compliment then the response is quite
a lengthy one oh you have a nice shirt
and you're supposed to according to him
you're supposed to say well you know
I've gotten my mother gave it to me or
something they have Foundation whereas
I'm not sure that's always the case the
danger when you try to make
generalizations is in fact very often
that's not the case and if someone says
to me you've got nice shirt I say thanks
I don't get into a lengthy explanation
of where I got the shirt terms like
speech acts and speech events then they
get into this whole critical period
hypothesis that we are best able to
learn languages When We're Young before
the age of 10 or 12 which is true
because the brain has not yet caught our
last and and kind of
hardened if you want around the native
language and we could just as easily
learn any language and later on it's a
little more difficult but then again
there's not much we can do with that if
I'm a 20 year old learning a language
whatever are the conditions that affect
the 20 year old that's going to affect
me it's not that useful to me as a
language learner to know that I should
have learned the language that language
at age eight uh he even goes on in
Alice's book he says you know
integrative motivation he says for
example uh English Canadians learning
French are very motivated to learn
French because they want to integrate
into the French society but that's
absolutely not the case most English
Canadians learning French are not at all
motivated to learn French some are and
those that are they learn but others
learn it as a subject that has to be
learned just like uh is the case I think
with language Learners in many countries
it's a subject they're not necessarily
that interested in learning those that
are motivated do learn uh it talks about
negotiating meaning
all these terms uh so and that's Alice
so I I gave him particular uh tents in
here but you know again I sort of
dog-eared some pages so here he talks
about uh
you know it's important to allow uh
students to select books themselves well
yes there you go that's a good thing to
say
um
you know things that affect the ability
to learn a word what makes it difficult
how it's spelled yes if you're learning
Spanish and there's a one-to-one
relationship between how it's spelled
and now it's pronounced that's going to
be a lot easier than if you're learning
English not to mention uh Arabic length
longer words are more difficult you know
four or five chapters and why it's
harder to learn those words uh all of
these things that are relatively obvious
you know if Learners do not know or they
must discover its meaning but guessing
from their structural knowledge of the
language guessing from an ally L1
cognate guessing from Context well they
don't necessarily have to guess I don't
guess if I'm reading online I just look
it up and and
I know full well that looking it up I
won't remember that word Iran Lake of
course the blue word becomes yellow the
next time I see it I'll know that I've
seen that word before but I'll look it
up again and again and again and
gradually those words become known so
some of this material is sort of
predates the Advent of the internet Paul
nation is an expert on language and
particular vocabulary acquisition
when uh and sort of noticing involves
decontextualization
decontextualization occurs when Learners
give attention to a language item as a
part of the language rather than as part
of a sentence or excuse me part of a of
a message
I don't know that I deliberately be
contextualize if I see a word in
different contexts eventually the sense
of that word grows on me while listening
or reading a learner notices that a word
is new or thinks I've seen that word
before or thinks that word is used
differently from the ways I've seen it
used before first of all if you're not
on a system like link you may not even
know that you've seen that word before
Learners negotiate the meaning of a word
with each other well that's again on the
Assumption as is often the case with
people who talk about language
acquisition
the assumption is that people are
sitting in a classroom creative or
generative use a third major process
that may lead to word being remembered
is Generation increasing number of
studies that show that generative
processing is an important factor
generative processing occurs when
previously met words are subsequently
met or used in ways that differ from the
previous meeting with the word yeah
that's something that occurs naturally
as you read more and more the more you
read the more you listen the more you
encounter words in different contexts
the more this kind of generative
processing takes place
they also recommends spending time on
Words Yeah the more time you spend on
one word the less time you have to spend
on acquiring more words and exposing
yourself to more of the language that
again can be a function of what you like
to do and how you like to learn here is
again Norbert Schmidt who is an expert
on acquiring vocabulary
again he probably the majority of words
do not have a one-to-one relationship
with a single referent
yeah words don't just mean one thing
words can mean a variety of things but
here again a natural process of
massive input massive reading and
listening encountering words in
different contexts gradually help you
sort of fill out the full scope of the
meaning of words talks about word
associations that we would learn the
word needle and then typically
associated with thread or pins or sharp
or so sure these are things that happen
naturally I'm not sure much is gained by
sort of explaining uh what does he say
here the other some explicit learning is
probably necessary to reach a vocabulary
size threshold that enables incidental
learning from reading
uh my experience is that for the longest
time there continue to be so many
unknown words that is unpleasant to rely
totally on the ability to infer and I
prefer uh learning a link looking up
every word putting it in my database
coming across it again and then
eventually seeing it become part of my
at least passive vocabulary which is the
first step towards making it part of
your active vocabulate so I'm not going
to go through all of these I've got a
Applied Linguistics here uh you know how
languages are learn language teaching
methodology but it is full of this
effort to complicate something that is
essentially quite straightforward and I
would refer everyone to Stephen krashen
I don't have to agree with everything
Steven crash and says uh he obviously is
much more expert than I am I draw on my
own experience he draws on research but
essentially uh it's a process of uh and
I would encourage everyone in fact I
will leave a link to Steven crash's
website uh the natural learning approach
the
um input hypothesis uh a number of you
know very clear and simple explanations
of how we learned which basically comes
down to lots of listening reading and
when you have acquired a certain
vocabulary then you start speaking with
more and more confidence the greater
your uh comprehension ability the
greater your vocabulary the more
confident you feel when speaking and if
you are more confident you will speak
better and everything will gradually
improve it's that simple it's not more
complicated than that and we like to
fake that at link We facilitate this
process of learning through massive
input by providing sort of training
wheels initially with uh easier content
like our many stories where there's a
lot of repetition and then the ability
to expand into more and more difficult
content content that's of Greater
interest and as long as you keep doing
that you are going to gradually learn
the language the emphasis is on the word
gradually and those
people who are motivated enough to learn
on their own and who feel confident
enough which isn't everyone to go out
there and learn on their own and choose
content of their own to listen to and
aren't necessarily waiting for a teacher
to spoon feed them those people are
going to learn better with or without
that's not to say that a teacher can be
helpful a teacher can be a tremendous
source of encouragement and stimulus and
advice but uh there are many things that
as Learners we can do to supplement and
complement what the teacher can provide
us with or
just to go out and fend for ourselves
and gradually develop uh you know an
ability and an understanding of
languages that are of interest to us so
thank you that I just kind of felt that
when I was looking through my library I
say wow it's that complicated I don't
think so anyway thanks for listening bye
for now